now with Arduino and rust-free pies if a
won't talk to be they jolly well will if
you stick a raspberry pie in the middle
of them just write a bit of software to
convert that to that and of course such
as the performance of this modern
hardware now and such is the range of
its networking capability that you can
do huge amounts you're not compromising
the overall quality of the chain in any
way I mean you know your rasp repair
solutions are really very very good so
what did we do in the old days if
hardware wouldn't talk to hardware be or
it could even be the software a produced
by some machine what had to be converted
into another software standard for some
other machines so whatever I think my
introduction to all this back in the day
was when we at Nottingham decided to
follow in the footsteps of Bell Labs
have our own typesetter we couldn't do
it exactly the same way that Bell Labs
did otherwise we'd have been in court
before we knew where we were but it
turned out that's in the gap between
Bell Labs doing it in about 1979 1980
and as doing it in about 1983 that
things had come on with this particular
typesetter now we're back in the era
that yes laser printers had been
invented they were there at Xerox PARC
HP knew all about it it was a technology
waiting to happen but it hadn't quite
happened yet and in the very early ages
if you wanted to be an early adopter of
a laser printer you'd be paying maybe 15
grand for resolution that was maybe only
300 lines to the inch so typical early
adopter problem yes it's the future but
the standard of it isn't fabulous at the
moment and it's darn expensive for what
it is and this was why we were caught
when deciding which kind of typesetter
we wanted and part of me was saying
should we wait another couple of years
three years maybe four you know laser
printer technology to improve
sufficiently and
the people doing the project with me
principally Jorge the math consultant
who wanted to typeset beautiful maths
papers now we were in that daft position
that we had to adopt old technology to
bridge the gap we were sold as the
future for a person that said this this
this Omnitech is wonderful it uses laser
technology it was a very early very high
quality laser printer but it's an
example of don't let the wrong industry
invent the future because they'll get it
wrong what they were obsessed by was
that traditional typesetting going all
the way back to hot metal and then
coming forward if you remember through
characters as filmstrips characters is
on an ultra high-definition cathode ray
tube yeah our customers will not accept
anything less than nine hundred and
seventy dots to the inch but when this
laser technology started to be developed
by Mergenthaler
they found that really it was happiest
at 300 dpi and you can imagine hard
customers will not accept 300 dpi so we
must drive this technology to the limits
what they ended up doing was having
ultra finder devoted toner ink and
special glossy paper that you had to use
not ordinary a4 or us letter I've had my
packet oh no what some of the paper yes
yes this is the actual paper out port
everything from the Omnitech and it is a
bit of descriptive prose about the
Omnitech yes a which is all very useful
and when you rub your finger over here
very glossy finished and if everything
was working and set it beautifully it
was actually a really rather commendable
effect and they claimed her to get 720
dots per inch and even that was just all
some of our customers won't like it
because the 202 using the previous
generation technology could get 972 dots
per inch so we're compromising our
standards already but they couldn't
drive it any higher than
20 even then it was a nightmare it was
like our sort of it as being run like
owning a very very very expensive car
like a oh how to know her but gassy or a
Doozer but there's only really way out
that is fine but it needs a complete
stripped-down and total service after
every hundred miles of music this was
the same we found that ideally it was
happiest if it was cleaned and totally
stripped down and done at the end of
every day ready for the next day you
know and it was just as and it wasn't
just as it was customers in America and
so on reported exactly the same problems
so we had to give up on the Omnitech and
we had to go back a generation we had to
ask Linotype to supplies with Elana
tronic 202 which you've also talked
about in the past previous generation
because it had a high-resolution cathode
ray tube inside it it was slow but he
was produced good quality output but it
was on bromide film or bromide paper
it needed developing it needed fixing
all of that hassle but we did it and it
worked absolutely fine so I hear you say
but you were driving these things not
with Linotype zone software you of
course we're using UNIX tear off an EQ n
because this was even just before donkus
tech it was happening just about the
same time as this but actually this was
about a year or 18 months before it so
we use Brian Kernighan zqn for
typesetting a mathematics equations
everything was hunky-dory but there was
a lie the manager of the project
thinking all of this
tear off typesetting stuff is happening
on the PDP 11 44 which we both were used
by the examiners department when they
eventually hand it over
because all this I remember this we said
this in the last video which was few
years ago but if you were trying to
typeset them the exam yes we were trying
to typeset all the exam papers for the
University of Nottingham because we were
being charged by outside typeset
companies
two thousand pounds a year they ignored
the dead easy English and history papers
which were perfectly straightforward
they concentrated on my dear friend
George's mathematics papers of which
there were lots which they started
rubbing their hands or saying oh this is
a job for a professional I can feel sums
of money like 10 pounds of page coming
here you know and all this kind of stuff
so yes that's what we were trying to do
but and in the end we did succeed but
one of the bigger problems was that
either of those types such as the
Omnitech or the 202 wanted to live in a
world of everything being done the
Mergenthaler Linotype way in other words
you didn't go to outside suppliers for
terminals you used a corer Tech's
preparation terminal supplied by
Mergenthaler Linotype everything was
like a special build for the particular
community that it was in the era of
generic machines and pcs was wasn't far
away but it wasn't quite there so we
were very non-standard
those typesetters wanted their input
down a parallel port now some of you
older types out there will know that
there's a printer parallel port on
old-fashioned pcs but back in this era
there was no compatibility about how
your parallel ports work so what are you
doing basically instead of sending 8
bits per character bang bang bang bang
back eight of them serially you
presented them on eight parallel wires
that's all you're doing so in principle
you make it eight times faster because
when you say send you're sending eight
times as much information problem is as
many of you know you only need that
parallel cable which has to be wide
enough now to maybe be 16 wide to take
eight bits going in and a reply of eight
bits coming back ribbon cable twisted
differential timings on the different
bits and your carats got somebody's
trodden on the cable it's not an easy
technology and it always struck me as
very significant that they did not
develop the universal parallel
to be high-speed no USB serial is so
much easier to cope with and the answer
to go faster is make the dead easy
protocol serial go faster don't mess
about with parallel but we were there we
had to mess with parallel I was stuck
there with two different specs for two
different parallel interfaces to learner
time machines one had been developed in
America one have been developed in the
UK and of course they were completely
different so what you did in those days
no Raspberry Pi I got a guy called Steve
Marchant an excellent hardware engineer
in our computing center to put me
together a box running a Zed 80 chip
it's coming out of the pdp-11 and it's
got the final if you like raw characters
with some control characters that are to
be sent to the typesetters to tell them
to either change for change spacing or
just typeset the letter a wherever you
are at the moment so all of those things
but they had to go in on this parallel
port so I had to develop the software on
a single border Zed 80 that took that
serial stream parceled it up into eight
bit parallel characters Exeter you know
in a wider buffer ready to go and sent
them through the parallel port to either
the Omnitech initially but laterally the
learner type 202 you send off your eight
bits you then pull the interface and say
oh you're ready did you get that and he
comes back and says ready
so you'll waiting all the time is it
ready for the nose character but it
worked now the thing for me in that era
was yes you have to have a hardware
person to design that interface for you
serial-in parallel-out
the thing that I thought well this is
great because I discovered I could just
get away with it I thought will I have
to write that stuff in that prom chip
which I'm going to burn and I'll have to
do that in assembler somewhere won't I
and Bernie no fortunately there was a
thing called the white Smith's C
compiler
developed by a team at Queen Mary
College University of London I think and
I was delighted to have it because they
had got a c2 z8 a compiler but that was
running on the PDP 1144
so it's an example of a cross compiler
it's not compiling code for PDP dex
stuff for use on this machine it's
compiling code for a foreign thing
called as l-82 which will go down a
serial line and end up being burnt onto
a prom to run in that board and even for
relatively everyday things I was doing
like wait for the carriage to come in is
it ready
pol the interface send off the next
character was that okay even for simple
routine things like that I found it's
such a relief to be able to write in C
and not I mean I'm not Ken Thompson we
are not talking about writing a whole
operating system but believe me just the
ability to write that simple interface
in programming C not in assembler made
the world a difference to me but it just
made me coming back E and reflect that
was the sort of level of of effort you
had to put into interfacing foreign Kate
that didn't want to speak to each other
did you have to test it on the actual
kit or did you have a simulator no
didn't have a simulator which was why I
had to explain to the examinations
departments it just shelled out the best
part of 35,000 pounds for the line to
type 202
I said I'm sorry and you will think this
is just taking it over but I need six
weeks to Commission this thing
I'm not Ken Thomas and Steve Martin's
not Joe Kahn and I don't know
no even they took six weeks for their
project which was arguably rather harder
than what we did I said we need several
weeks to Commission this because when we
are trying its interface saying how fast
are we likely to be able to feed these
characters at it because it's going to
come back and say you've gotta wait for
the ready and the answer was it was
comfortingly slow I didn't have any
timing problem
to worry about Annie went plod plod and
by the end of 84 we really had using the
tool to type sake the complete
university of Nottingham's papers all of
them for the very first time in-house
what then happened perhaps to complete
the story is that after doing that for
two years even George my consultant said
you know
these are only examples I do wonder if
people would find them acceptable to
just have them done on this new 300 dots
per inch laser printer maybe people
won't mind most people never noticed you
know it was using x roman the math
symbols were there the fact it was a bit
grainy compared to the super duper broma
most people didn't care that sort of
thing and that's an example of how if
you're wedded in to a high quality
industry you find it incomprehensible
that the great unwashed will accept a
lesser quality than you do but of course
that rules the world in a sense I mean
Liz printed more like 600 dpi now aren't
they so was that switching when you
mentioned that that was switching to the
laser at the Apple razor oh yes it's
actually saying well we've had the
Dalarna tonic to to thanks Lana tonic
you're a great machine they still
continue to use it for very high quality
jobs but frankly for the grunt work
which is getting the exam papers done
people thought it was a miracle they
they would cheerfully vote for lots and
lots more 300dpi and do everything like
that then wait a bit longer and get an
even smoother looking version of an exam
paper so I learned a lot from that
really about what level of technology do
you really need and what your customers
really want even though one or two of
our number might have thought it to be
how should we say abominable that they
had such low standards and nevermind
that's what we need that's what we use
it's been I think it's been the death of
many a specialist industry the idea of
it's good enough it's like every car
needs to be a Rolls Royce
customers for cars won't accept anything
less until the Model T comes along and
they're initially deprecated but then
quietly people like them saying oh well
for what I use it for it's good enough
you know makes for an executable binary
the net effect of slotting that T
diagram against here slightly downwards
is to show you that the C you've written
gets converted into binary and the net
output from this process it produces out
a program that you probably store in a